oh shoot oh sam just got it to the face
oh and now walker can't move a [ __ ] you
can't mess with the door melange not
like this
she knew the password to his arm
it wasn't him don't do it oh my god
[Music]
on disneyplus.com oh my god
bro that is not minute made that is
human blood
my god well you don't do steroids kids
welcome back to new rock stars the
falcon in the winter soldier episode 4
titled the whole world is watching and
with the whole world watching john
walker
make it to world star seriously
now more than ever mt what the
falcon is going on like
oh jesus lord that man murked a man
live in front of everyone this is inside
marvel it's new rockstars after show for
the falcon the winter soldier i'm eric
voss here with
mt empty how are you feeling after this
um i'm feeling like john walker's in a
bit of trouble eric with a capital t
that rhymes with the s that stands for
shield no
rhyme with us if i were tommy back told
i kind of made that work it's okay
i still believe in you hey six years
from now i'll be cringing
as i try to fall asleep thinking
well let's do a quick recap episode 4
opens in a flashback to wakanda
finally break free from his winter
soldier soldier brainwashed sebastian
stan crushed it in the scene it was so
beautiful
so powerful i was like this man is
gunning for that emmy and they should
give it to him
because i can't cry like that i cannot
neither can i
unless it's genuine but if you ask me to
do it while i'm pretending to be someone
else i don't know if i could well
uh then essentially this episode uh
fight me on this but
we get basically a half hour of nap time
with the flag smashers
uh look i have a whole theory i mean
last uh breakdown i talked about how
they did have to do a lot of reshooting
and recutting to make the flagsmaster
storyline different than i think what
was going to be a virus storyline
and i think that's what we're seeing now
is this just kind of weird back and
forth exposition
and it's amazing that they were able to
get this much out of it
but it culminates in this kind of
scramble where
um the serum vials spill everywhere uh
zemo muscle tops them
uh but there's one last one that gets
away
walker snatches it and then he gets his
masculinity triggered by the
well they dora his ass they're so great
in this scene
uh but now that he is feeling this way i
guess that juice is loose
uh he he juices up off screen and then
um in another fight lamar hoskins sadly
dies when carly punches him into a
column and then walker
[Music]
he loses it he takes it out on flag
smasher nico
as onlookers record this shield smeared
in blood the blood of terrorism
oh that's right yeah dude i feel like
the internet has gotten crazy over the
past couple of days because we have that
winter soldier fight and badger poor
all over the news with uh you know sam
in the background and then now we have
a murder um by the new captain america
and i'm sure
the government is not too jazzed about
it
a murder that you could argue was um at
least emotionally justified but dude
took it way too far that was savage he
didn't need to kill the guy the way he
did and i was honestly thinking he was
going to decapitate him right i was yeah
whoa he's bringing down that thing right
on his neck but no this is disney plus
so we kind of just cut to off screen and
then the shield can be covered in blood
this isn't the boys
heads would be rolling i was so shocked
that like yeah i did thought
that they were going to decapitate them
but i was like yeah this is disney plus
i
didn't think that i was like they the
fact that they even took it that far
that we even got the blood and that the
brutal bludgeoning
was kind of uh it's pretty impressive
pretty intense
yeah so we're going to talk in this
episode about the dark history that led
walker to this moment why
i mean we kind of know why he snapped
this moment but what were what was the
thousand cuts that led to him uh making
that decision
and really what this means for the
legacy of captain america and the mcu
going forward
we're also going to talk about things
like what to expect from sharon carter
or zemo going forward because you know
there's a lot to talk about here but
before we continue real quick i am
wearing our latest obsession shirt it's
anarchy assembled you can get this at
newrockstarsmerch.com
if you do you'll unlock an additional
option to write in custom shoutouts that
will appear at the bottom
of the screen in these inside marvel
after shows for example we got raymond
who says do you guys think that cap
never came back and old mancap is a
skrull
[Music]
no that's an interesting theory but i
don't old mancap
has an interesting story to tell i don't
think they're gonna make him a scroll
line yeah that would
sort of cheapen his return in his whole
story so
yeah i don't think that that's kevin
feige's point but i do think we'll have
some interesting reveals of people
who have been squirrels the whole time i
but they're gonna pick and choose their
battles with that in the mcu i don't
think old cap is that
and then uh pat though stock says all
aboard the zola train
okay hey i i'm here with you buddy up in
the dining car just picking out before
they kick me out to make me go back to
my seat
the problem is um we're running out of
episodes
and we have seen zero signs of uh
it could easily be on episode five
episode six then you never know where
you never know you gotta keep faith on
the zola train that's right that's right
next episode's supposed to be a big one
and then uh denise carter says ah super
fan of you guys boston mt i'm doing
zemo dance right now oh thanks so
are we hey we got this emoji
we got a full hour of that [ __ ] it
didn't take several years to release it
either so that was great
all right mt what is our first what the
falcon well i'm glad you asked eric
because i first what the falcon of the
day
is what the falcon happened to john
walker to make him
so violent yeah we have some listeners
on stereo who are asking the same thing
this came from where it's going to
happen now john walker has killed
a potentially innocent man um a freedom
fighter
um in the name of america yeah another
interesting way to frame that question
like what's gonna happen to him now how
did he get here and where does he go
from here
um well let's remind ourselves that uh
exactly what happened john ends this
episode having juiced up on the super
soldier serum he was unable to save his
partner lamar hoskins
lamar had stopped carly from stabbing
john carly punched lamar into a pillar
killing him she was even kind of shocked
by how strong she was but
it happened and then john loses it and
he takes it out on a flag smasher nico
remember nico this poor dude he was the
one who grew up as a fan of captain
america
he talked about how his grandfather
fought alongside the allied forces
in world war ii of which cap was a part
of
and now this dude's blood is smeared all
over the stars and strikes what i
i mean if if there's any way for you to
go
i would and i was a cat fan i would not
be terribly
upset about being killed by a captain
america
um i mean getting killed is not ideal
but you know but it's like if someone's
gonna take me out might as well exactly
i grew up admiring yeah if it was chris
evans captain america about to take my
life and be like wow i must have
deserved it
i must have i must have done something
wrong i feel the same way mt i grew up
having
a bobby's world poster where he was
picking his nose and it said i'm not
picking my nose according to my brain
and my whole life i've wanted if
anything were to take me out of this
world i want it to be
uh howie mandel's animated proudhood
self
just strangling me slowing slowly and
putting his finger up my nose and saying
i'm pointing out i'm gonna poke your
brain boss
i'm gonna poke your brain through your
nose that's what i roll around
thinking of all night like oh god that's
where is he gonna come where is he gonna
come
it's how he's he's coming he's already
in me that's the truth
yeah oh boy that's not gonna get taken
out of context at all
oh you just made it weird i was talking
about astral projection and
ah damn it well we gotta cut that now
let's do that that's a
a stereo exclusive is what that means
okay let's talk about how
this happened so lamar reminded us that
erskine told steve rogers in the first
cap film that the serum just kind of
amplifies what you already are inside
and so what's inside john walker what
seems like a boy scout
right like lamar praised his medals of
honor but walker made this interesting
reference to what he and lamar had to do
in afghanistan
and he said uh you and i both remember
what we had to do to get those medals
it just kind of sounds like they had to
make um
some in the moment of action like
choices horrible choices as all soldiers
do sometimes
they might have had to you know
unfortunately let some of their
own men die even though that's not
necessarily their fault but they
just feel that guilt with them and then
it doesn't feel like a medal of honor it
feels like a
medal of a survivor's guilt yeah like a
medal of like shame almost and like
yeah like they definitely had to do some
things to that led to the
the depths of their um fellow soldier
buddies but i'm sure that they did
horrible things to like the people
in afghanistan that too um you know like
women children like war is a very
ugly thing and like we don't see a lot
of the very horrific sides of war and
they are just alluding to that it's like
you know
everyone thinks that we're heroes but we
don't i don't really feel like a hero
with all that
stuff that we did right and uh
and like we know that this that john has
not been okay
this entire series john has not been
okay like when we started with him in
that locker room you could tell that he
was not comfortable with this position
he kind of longed for the days of just
uh being a simple football star where he
could
you know hang out with his like uh
football buddies with his
with his girlfriend at the time who's
now his wife uh and then ever since then
we've seen him looking
and this is just so great by white
russell that he's been able to show this
non-verbally
because he's been looking frustrated and
impatient he rubs his head as if he's
suffering from migraines
um something has been nagging at him and
in this episode do you see him and i
know this isn't that big a deal but he
stops shaving
it looks like his hair was like growing
long over the course of that day
because like it looked like he just had
a bit of scruff and by the end of the
episode he had like a full eric boss
faux scruff like just a little fuzz to
keep his uh non-existent chin from
distracting
yeah he's trying to steal your whole
flow he was like that's eric boss he's a
he's a suave man
i gotta see him but it's like for him
it's a big deal because he's such a
polished
soldier and now he's just like letting
himself go he's like
yeah he doesn't he doesn't give a [ __ ]
anymore yeah and it's scary to see
i honestly it's it's literally the
weight of the shield and the
in him trying to fill steve rogers shoes
that has been driving him crazy like the
fact that he was even
in that country um looking for
uh sam and bucky he wasn't supposed to
be there because at the end of the last
episode he was like
we're gonna do things a little bit off
the book and like they're not gonna care
um like how we do it as long as we get
it done and so
you know he's just i'm willing to do
whatever it takes to prove myself into
the
in the eyes of the public that i'm
fitting and um so he stops shaving and
he starts to do
some crazy stuff and uh now uh a man is
dead
uh now uh if you've been following along
with what
uh the history of john walker is in the
comics you could kind of see this snap
as an inevitable thing um as many snaps
are inevitable
because in the comics john walker always
kind of had a big ego he was a very
different character he's like
aggressively lobbying for the cap title
he stages these rallies he stages fake
attacks on himself to make him look like
more of a captain america style hero
he kind of goes from being this
character named super patriot to
actually replacing steve rogers as cap
when steve walks away from the shield
and then this gang called the watch dogs
kill his parents and that's the moment
he snaps he descends
into the murderous rage we see so in
this show lamar hoskins has kind of
filled that role his death uh
has kind of made him lose it all right
daddy hoskins
yeah but i again i gotta hand it to uh
to wyatt russell because like the way he
has played this character has made him
so more sympathetic and you you don't
want to see him it feels heartbreaking
when he
picks up that shield and brings it down
in rage because you know the human that
was there before that monster took over
yeah and like it's it's it's so sad
seeing
him trying his best to be a really good
captain america because he
you know his heart's in the right place
his mind just isn't in the right place
unfortunately because he
is you know he does have all this
probably ptsd from what he's
been doing in afghanistan and like the
weight of being a soldier
and like him wanting to do the right
thing um it's just
in like with lamar's death it just threw
him right over the edge
and you know with wha did zemo say that
uh with about power
and making um revealing who you really
are or something like that
yeah i think they were all kind of
talking about this episode uh lamar
hawkins brought it up with him
and then like yeah but zemo was saying i
think this whole lesson was a lesson on
the dangers of uh superheroes
they they linked the term superhero with
supremacist which i find interesting
because we associate supremacists with
like white supremacists with like uh
with bigotry and extremism uh but
really they come from the same kind of
notion because uh
johann schmidt and uh arnhem zola were
trying to create
the super man and the idea the history
of superhumans
in uh in superheroes and american comics
in the 20th century
was out of that whole idea that like
jerry siegel making uh
and joe schuster making superman in the
30s
we're trying to recapture and
americanize the version of that because
up until that point
it was the nazis trying to experiment on
the idea of how do we create
the perfect aryan human being and the
boys has explored this history really
well on amazon with like homelander and
stormfront
and that whole history of like what it
means to manufacture a superhero and how
that's a little problematic
captain america over at marvel was kind
of the same thing uh it was uh those
guys joe simon trying to create
like no we on our first cover we're
gonna show this american version of the
superman punching hitler in the face and
rejecting
that creepy version of it and saying
that we can have an ideal to strive
towards
but like looking back on the history of
it it's just another side of the same
coin of like
this idea of we need to create a peak
perfect human being there's no such
thing as that and when you do try to do
that
you're gonna break someone's mind uh and
that whole idea of supremacy and super
soldier
it's not that far off from each other
it's not too crazy to say those two are
linked
so are you saying right now eric that
nobody's perfect and that we gotta
work it every day till we get it right
is that what you're saying
you put it in such better terms
but no yeah you're 100 right because
like i do like the link between um
you know the supremacy and superpowers
because that like you said
that's literally what is going on like
uh yeah like a weird
like evolutionary supremacy in a way
it's like let's make the
i believe the germans at least in the
comics anyway um the ubermensch
is that that was uh either kierkegaard
or nietzsche's term i think his
kierkegaard came up with that idea the
ubermensch
yes this the superman um and so
you know with with these new super
powered people
more popping up in marvel as as time
goes on
you know there is this weird like us
versus them sort of thing
probably going on within the minds of
the regular people it's like oh no
like it with mutants coming like perfect
example it's like oh no these mutants
are probably gonna
when the mutants come they're being like
oh my god like we feel threatened and
that's where that that mutant hate comes
from so like
yeah this i this is that those are those
seeds of like supremacy that they're
starting to
just to sew in so that we so that the
viewers can sort of get
um adjusted to thinking um and getting
ready to think the way that the mcu
populace
um could be thinking or get an idea of
how they could be thinking in the future
agreed
yeah and i think but now we have to
think about what does this mean for
captain america going forward the whole
world now sees the
captain america figure they've known
have a shield with blood all over it
after he's savagely butchered someone in
the street in the public
so is this where we're headed is uh is
the captain america legacy are they
gonna have to destroy the shield by the
end of this is that the only way forward
or does it just end up in a museum uh or
does it have to get
you know re-appropriated to someone
who's none of these people
well first of all eric it's gotta be
washed uh first because uh that blood is
uh
it can't stay there leave it like
invincible
leave it as a reminder like
exactly oh that would be a badass little
thing it's like just like painted blood
on there
but no um it would be i think that
that a that's a really good question and
b like i said before
the john walker and lamar hoskins were
not supposed to be there
and so having in like
with countries they are like countries
around the world sort of hate the united
states in a way
because of their the history of us like
sort of just going into countries
and just doing whatever we want and like
not asking permission and so
a murder happening on foreign soil by an
american agent
on like international news everywhere is
not going to go well
and so i mean yeah even if that guy who
killed was labeled an international
terrorist like harley
morgenthau all the flag smashers were
considered terrorists it still looks
really really unsettling
and terrifying yeah to have the stars
and stripes of the shield
and it's covered in blood of someone you
killed in the street it's just
not gonna go it's not a good image i
just think it's going to
um it's gonna sour people on the idea of
captain america but i honestly
feel like it's going to draw battle
lines i think some people are going to
be like yes finally this is a captain
america we wanted
you know that's how it works in society
is it something we're like yup the guy
deserved it
and i've wanted to see some blood
proudly smeared because that's what
this is all about is the you know we're
not afraid to kill our enemies
when they attack us like i think that's
going to be the creepy side effect of
this it's going to politicize
captain america someone who should never
be politicized
it should be someone who just represents
the goodness in america and the good
virtues and values
but do those exist anymore in in 2021 or
in this case in 2024 in a post-flip
society
and in our world you know opposed to a
lot of other things society
would say those virtues uh don't exist
some would say those virtues never
existed it's all about
like zemo was saying it's like making
icons into into things that
can't really exist like making
captain america this like god figure and
like there's a danger in that
and so yeah i don't really know
what happens with the with the captain
america legacy after this but like
it makes a pretty good case for sam
that's all i know
oh for sure i'm sure john walker is
clearly not
my cap and not mt's kat von d oh no
no but i think this has this has to end
i think john walker's done i
i don't uh he's either gonna have to
retire or he's gonna have to be
destroyed and it's just gonna be so hard
to watch
well if you think about it he's now
juiced up and the government
doesn't really know that yet so like
knowing
the united states government they're
probably going to be like hold on let's
let's think about this because now we
have a wi-fi strong man
and this makes us even better so like we
can just
brush us under the rug and now we're
happy that we have a strong captain
america again
yeah but i i still think no matter who
is excited about him
we know people hate super soldiers in
this world uh you know
i think there's a good chance that
either carly or zemo
or sam or bucky are going to be the one
to kill john walker or
i don't necessarily want to see this but
i could see
a dark path ahead where he might have to
destroy himself
ooh that would just do it by accident or
something that would be some dark so
destructive that destruction could be
turned
inward i think i mean that's a really
interesting idea i never really thought
about i'm gonna think about that
tonight i don't like to think about it
either to be honest but it's just like
what more could be done
this guy is in the same way that like on
the boys like what could be a line ahead
for homeland or well homeland is
essentially a god walking on earth but
it's like
there's no way there's no future for
characters like that they're beyond
redemption
uh i think at this point you know uh so
either either they're gonna take a
redemption arc
and then he just steps away from the
shield but he can't keep going on
this is a short fuse that he is on i
think yeah
and like he's he's only getting more and
more unhinged and so
it's it's only a matter of time before
so
something's got to give in some type of
way like hopefully it's not dark
but like good god like this man can't
handle the pressure he just wasn't right
for the job
yeah i mean looking at how alliances are
i think
uh basically john walker's gonna be an
army of one
like he's uh he's gonna be on his own
path i don't even think he's going
to fight on behalf of his country
anymore he's just gonna go
rogue and i think sam and bucky are
gonna have to join up with the flag
smashers
we already heard sam this episode
basically echoing their talking points
he's essentially a flag smasher he's
just not paying his dues yet
you know so i think those that's where
things are gonna be
uh aligned i think sharon carter is
gonna be helping out with her weird
satellite tech in madrid and then uh
zemo is gonna be a rogue agent of his
own so you gotta imagine the two rogue
agents that are out there and everyone
else is just trying to get them from
causing more collateral damage
i think uh i think there's more of a
future for zemo in this universe than
there is for john walker
yeah for sure i'm just saying if one has
to kill the other i think zemo still
might kill john walker
um if if anyone's gonna survive this
whole series it's gonna be zemo because
they're
obviously setting zemo up for bigger
things in the mcu as they should because
he's a very big force
um but with john walker it's like he
could easily
we could easily see the beginnings and
ends of john walker in this series
absolutely i could imagine this being a
tragic cautionary tale of what happens
when
the wrong people get that super soldier
serum and it like
exactly and like with a cautionary tale
like this it just serves to make
steve rogers look even better because
you know he had all this power and he
didn't
he was a very selfless person to the
degree that he could lift
mjolnir which is insane well before we
get to because we have a lot more other
questions we want to uh
talk about first we want to thank some
people who helped us make this episode
uh our friends at blue chew this episode
was sponsored by bluetooth blue chew is
making waves and
bringing more confidence to the bedroom
blue chew is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in chewable form
and a fraction of the cost bluetooth
tablets combat all forms of ed
and can help men gain that extra
confidence for when it is time to
perform
you don't need blue super soldier serum
there's another little blue friend that
you can chew
goes down a bit easier doesn't make it
crazy just gives you that confidence
um blue chew is an online prescription
service so no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversation no wait
in line at the pharmacy and it ships
right to your
discreet package sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days and it's all
done
online bluetooth licensed medical
providers work with you to find the
right ingredient and strength for your
prescription
and if you don't like swallowing pills
no problems blue chews tablets are
chewable so for extra confidence when
it's time to perform
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information
and we got a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth free when you
use a promo code inside marvel at
checkout just pay five dollars in
shipping
that's bluechew.com promo code inside
marvel to receive your first month free
and we thank bluetooth for sponsoring
this episode
and we want to thank mint mobile for
sponsoring us there's always a catch
with
the big wireless providers with all that
fine print
so when i heard mint mobile offers
premium wireless service starting at
just 15 bucks a month i thought
hey what the catch here but after
speaking with them i found out that
there is no catch
mint mobile's secret sauce is that they
are the first company to sell wireless
service online only
by cutting out retail stores there's no
crazy overhead costs that get passed
down to you in the form of those mystery
fees
mint just passes on the sweet savings
and they're sending me a sim card that
i'm excited to try the service and save
some money
and uh people looking for extra savings
mint mobile offers premium wireless for
just 15 bucks a month all plans
come with unlimited talk and text plus
high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network
use your own phone with any mint mobile
plan and keep your same phone number
along with all your existing contacts
and if you're not 100 satisfied mobile
has you covered with their 7 day money
back guarantee switch to mint mobile and
get premium wireless service starting at
just 15
a month to get your new wireless play
for just 15 bucks a month and get the
phone shipped to your door for free go
to mintmobile.com
marvel that's mintmobile.com marvel cut
your wireless bill to 15 bucks a month
at mmo.com marvel hey and before we
continue real quick if you've been
following along with our show fitness
origins that comes out on sundays it's
it's me and tommy
just getting in shape in a real nerdy
fitness challenge it's a lot of fun uh
philip has brought us involve brought us
in on that process
but there's a whole bunch of other ways
you can get involved with this including
doing these
workouts uh at home because that's how
tommy and i are doing them
and i just go down to my apartment rec
room tommy does it in his living room
and we're able to get in shape just by
doing these kind of simple core things
just like laying out on the ground and
planking and you can
follow along with these by subscribing
to the epic hero fitness
youtube channel and you can see the
proper versions of how to do all of
these so that you can kind of follow
along and join this journey with us
uh so again just go to the epic hero
fitness youtube channel go ahead and
subscribe
hopefully by the time you do that those
uh all those videos will be up
uh i know they're working really fast to
try to get them up there's also a bunch
of bloopers on there
um because there's a lot a lot that
aren't cannot even fit into
the episode that we want to release
there so that's a great place to go
check that out if you're interested in
fitness origins on the channel all right
so we have uh another question
um that we want to take from stereo
do you think that sharon has been
pardoned because the cia
wants somebody on the inside of the
power brokers in a circle
the question there basically is what the
falcon is sharon carter's connection to
the power broker
what do you think mt i mean i definitely
think
that she is working for the power broker
in some degree whether or not that is um
you know undercover as a cia agent we've
yet to see i
i do also suspect that she's doing some
type of undercover work with the ciao or
something that she cannot tell
anybody about even bucky and sam um
but she is uh working for the power
broker and has
seemingly gained the power brokers trust
in some degree well there's been a lot
of uh
theories theorizing about sharon carter
you know
like is she a power broker herself is
she uh
deep cover is she deep deep cover is she
a triple agent and it's like
folks two episodes left two episodes
left and we have a lot of other story
lines that they seem to care
way more about than what is sharon
carter's deep cover now
look tv shows do this all the time right
like if you watch 24
or if you watch alias that kind of [ __ ]
it's like whoa you're
actually serving this you know so i i
wouldn't put it past the show i wouldn't
put it past the show to make sharon
carter a scroll
uh i think that's doable as well i'm
just saying uh
if she is working on behalf of the cia
would the cia
want to fund an asset in madrid
to live as in an expensive ass penthouse
in high town
trading expensive stolen art i don't
think the cia that would just be too
many steps for the cia
she could just live uh you know simply
meagerly and kind of work in his
organization and live low profile
rather than live this lavish lifestyle
where she's running around killing
people
that's not how the cia that's not how
any government-funded person operates
that's what they were already that's a
good cover right
right and that's what's hard to argue
with people about this it's like that's
exactly what they want you to think it's
like
i'm sure sure but do i think they're
gonna give us eight minutes of a scene
to explain this when we have two
episodes left i don't think that's the
show's priority
you know but uh this is just an example
of it's
you bring up a lot of questions when you
write a character so bizarrely as they
have written sharon carter on this show
she is over the top she's weird she's
not who she was
and i don't understand her character i i
don't know
i feel like the writers didn't
understand her character but kevin
feige's like no you got to bring her
back in this they're like okay fine
we're just gonna
make her freaking crazy it'd be one
thing again it'd be one thing if she was
alive during the blip
because then we're talking years and
years and years like seven years two
years on the run five years of the blip
that would change her
no this woman was on the run for two
years
she dusted her face appeared on the dust
screens uh at the beginning of end game
gone for five years uh re-materializes
five years later
um who knows where and then six months
later she's
able to like get to this point where
she's a crazy arts dealer would the ci
even care about her
at that point as to use her as an asset
to get to the powerboard no i just think
she
works for the power broker and that
explains
why she's she has access to all the
stolen art he just thinks she's
really good at this and she's kind of
serving him and making him money and
that kind of thing
hmm well like in regards to the whole
like uh
sharon carter showing up on the on in
end game in the as
list of the vanished i think that they
just didn't know where she was
i think that she was probably you think
that she was actually dusted oh no
i think she was dusted i think that was
that was the screenwriter
implication of that now scott lang was
not dusted he was just gone but like
disappeared in the quantum realm it's
not the same thing as just like not
picking up your phone
like cap would have checked in with her
she would not have refused to answer
cap's call
you know like she showed up on that
board and that was the idea that these
are people who have actually dusted with
the exception of scott lang because that
was setting up
when scott lang reappears and they're
like oh we thought you dusted
if she was just hiding in madrapore
there's no way she would not have picked
up the phone if cap called she was
desperate for
attention from the avengers during that
time it's true so
i i just don't buy that i think uh i
just think she's a weird character on
the show and that weird character forces
us to like look at a bunch of crazy
tweets from people and i'm like we're
getting at the point now in the show
folks where we want it to be something
that it is not
yeah because this is just uh this is a
show that they had to like re-edit and
they had to change a lot of story lines
around because there was a whole coveted
storyline
and we're lucky it is as good as it is
i'm loving what they're doing with
the character of john walker i love the
history of bucky and showing
how the wakandans helped him clear his
memory i'm liking the story with uh sam
wilson
and how he's having to deal with the
economic realities of being the guy he
is
like that's interesting to me but the
flag smashers but sharon carter all this
stuff is is weird and it's because they
had to recut it it's not because
they have some deeper conspiracy at work
i say we release the pre-covered cut
i'm just kidding i'm gonna do a whole
video on that that's gonna come out on
the channel on monday because that
i think the world needs to like step
back and look at whoa
there's a whole other storyline here and
that's why things are as weird as they
are that's why characters leave these
loose ends
um because otherwise it doesn't make
sense to write characters the way
they're writing them
if you are setting it up to be uh twist
reveal like that would yeah
if they did reveal her to be the power
broker herself or
you know working these other angles like
if she does become a scroll i'm gonna be
a little disappointed i'm gonna be like
yeah jesus christ another one like yeah
i was sort of like
it's the same way with a spider-man far
from home with uh nick fury and maria
hill they had a really dope moment
with uh the rocket launcher and i was
like oh man this is one of my favorite
nick fury moments it's like oh
it wasn't nick fury it's just another
scroll all right cool yeah
i'll say that i was okay with fury and
maria hill being a squirrel just because
that felt fun and you can get you can do
one of those but if you like
everyone's and every property they did
it in one division they have a squirrel
showing up in loki it's like
it's okay if it's just like a fun
background goofball thing like i liked
how in one division it was someone who
we didn't know and didn't already
you know we didn't really care about so
i'm okay with that but like
you gotta it's not gonna hit as hard and
secret invasion if you make it
characters we know
before secret invasion you know that's
that's the whole cool thing and the
secretivation of who can you trust
because that comic series opens with
like a ton of people
between like you know a spider woman and
hank pym and a bunch of people was like
whoa
whoa whoa whoa how long have you been a
squirrel you know so you need to say
that you got to save that
um anyway i've been ranting too much
let's take uh
let's take another question oh actually
i
think this is one hey love the show guys
it's amazing
thank you what did you guys think about
they kept lingering when
um lamar was tied up to that dripping
water
and then they did flash back to him
during the chase down scene at the end
i know like his spine got shattered but
any possibility he could be alive or
come back or just
anything he's a great character yeah um
uh
i think i think lamar is dead uh he felt
his pulse i don't think lamar juiced up
on anything
um i think the idea of that scene the
emotional context of that scene is that
lamarck died and i think
not uh having him not be dead would be
too much of a
wait what you kind of lose your audience
yeah that much yeah
no lamar is 100 dead and like like you
said it's it was
lamar was john walker's jiminy cricket
he sort of he was like you know in a
weird way
being like his like reason it's like hey
man why don't you calm down you're kind
of being a little bit
crazy but like he did support john and
he was like i'm with you
through the end of the line in their own
way but like you know
it's when he with his death that was
supposed to symbolize
there's no real turning back for john
walker this is just who i am now
i'm going to be 100 ego driven there's
no one stopping me
my link to my childhood that you know
well my childhood best friend is gone
you know and the only one that could
really maybe help him turn around is
maybe his wife but his wife doesn't come
with him
to work so i don't think so right
so yeah lamar is dead but i'm glad you
asked about this dripping water because
that was really weird uh they kept like
when lamar was trying to
get out of the the restraints with his
knife
they kept framing him behind like and if
you look in the wide shot of that room
there are showers on the side there are
kind of like these open shower stalls
um that because i think this facility
was used as a hospital so i think they
kind of had that
set up for if they need to have showers
they're just going to open there
um yeah but i guess one of the showers
is still dripping because some people
don't turn the knob all the way back and
they're working it's not environmentally
friendly make sure it's all the way off
yes uh yeah so but i think what this was
honestly was just we know director carl
skoglin likes to do these stylistic
flourishes like
how she put the camera up and bucky in
the therapist's face
in that opening episode it's just like
why are we doing this it's kind of just
more of a
an artistic choice and i think the idea
was like it's the feeling that time is
running out
even though kind of this artificial
ticking clock in a scene
but just like a dripping water something
that kind of gives you anxiety
and i think that moment lamar is like
i'm missing out on the fight i'm feeling
anxiety
uh and i need to get out but like it was
almost framed in a way of like
oh oh obama's about to go off or uh oh
lighter fluid or gasoline
and he's gonna get on fire like it's
just one of these weird things where
i was like what was the intent behind
that is he drowning is he like the
colonel from that zemo drowned upside
down it's like careful this drip drip
drip is gonna fill this room and you're
right
i had the same questions like why did
they time up why don't they just kill
them
you know if they're trying to kill these
guys who are threats to them it's just
it drives me nuts in movies and shows
where it's like tie them up it's like no
like the james bond like yes tie him up
and then i'm going to tell him my plan
and then
have this really elaborate way of
killing him he's going to escape
yeah i mean these flag smashers weren't
carly who i believe is the most extreme
of them so i can understand
why they might react to carly bombing
that that building the last episode and
being like well we'll just tie this one
up
um but like it's just like well you know
what's gonna happen if you tie him up
he's just gonna come back and he's gonna
punch you and then
he he died because yeah and then created
all these other problems
anyway so that's what it was i think it
was carly skoglyn the director stylistic
choice for what that dripping water was
and again
one of these loosened choices where it's
like everyone on the show
behind the scenes just seems to be
making choices that are good in their
own tunnel
but it does not seem to be a big union
with each other and i think it's because
they had to butcher this thing back
together in post-production
and like all the cool stuff that carries
oakland probably intended
uh had to be scrapped um in order to
make a sensible narrative
and ultimately and i don't have any
shame pointed towards that because
that's how all movies and tv are you
taking the best
you got on your date you stitch it
together in post-production
and you do your best to salvage what you
have and produce a narrative with the
with audio
mixing with the with editing with vfx
that's what all of it is uh and we've
learned that lesson very much with the
snyder cut like john
zack snyder could completely assemble a
fully new narrative just really with
post production using
other footage that he had so uh and
completely changed the meaning of a work
and i think that's what they had to do
here that's all rationality and logic
eric i think the real reason behind the
dripping water
is that they wanted to make lamar feel
like he had to pee
so labar that's why lamar had to he was
cutting himself out he's like i gotta go
i gotta get out of these restraints
and that's what gave him the motivation
yeah they also had his hand like just
sitting in a warm glass of water
and now you're gonna hear yourself
battle this battle
sounds like a freak head bond thing
battle star
um okay uh let's ask another what the
falcon here
the next one the falcon of the day is
what the falcon was the meeting behind
sam and bucky's reaction to zemo saying
there has never been
another steve rogers right yeah during
that
supremacist conversation i might be
reading too much into that but
i feel like they just kind of they
didn't answer and i think
the obvious implication that scene was
no one can have
the the unique moral character that
steve rogers had
but that was that was a one-and-done
kind of thing um
but uh they could also be referring to
isaiah bradley in that moment they're
like well we did have another steve
rogers figure who just like because
the government didn't take care of him
and accused him
uh that like he was unfortunately just
stuck where he is now
but like i can't help but wonder in the
first episode there are these conspiracy
theories that old cap is on the moon
like is that same in that moment being
like well there was another steve rogers
we had one who went back to time another
old one came back
from somewhere and he's on the moon now
i don't know if he's on the moon he's
somewhere i think is the implication
he's
uh so i kind of just like their hush
hush moment there
did you see anything there mt i mean i
i do tend to think lean more towards the
you know
the obvious implication of like all
right there hasn't really been another
steve rogers he's like this really
you know great guy who was like this was
sort of his fluke in the system and like
become this
hero um but i mean there could be
something to that line i mean they did
share a really weird reaction to demo
saying that so like
hey maybe i mean just to like you know
stoke the conspiracy fire
maybe they know of a steve rogers scroll
and like
they're not like there's two steve
rogers and there technically has been
another steve rogers in our past
but like i mean i i obviously don't
really think that but like hey
there that you're totally right though
there was a weird reaction there
and there could be something that we
learn at the end of the series that we
look back and be like oh so that's what
that reacts with that oh okay
yeah um but yeah that was a really
strange reaction
let's take another question from our
listeners on stereo here
let's do it what would have happened had
the dora melange
actually taken the shield instead of
leaving it behind
oh that is a good what the falcon why
did they
allow john walker to keep the shield
assuming it was made of vibranium
um this is a question i've wondered
about
my only thought is that either wakanda
is just
okay with the captain america shield
just being what it is and it's they no
longer identify it as their property
even though it is made of vibranium i
would assume they would know that it's
made of vibranium
because they have a very good history of
keeping track of
where all their vibranium goes in the
world and uh
my thinking is that this shield is not
made of vibranium
and that's why she's okay because my
long theory is that because old cap came
from an alternate timeline that that
shield could have been made out of
proto-adamantium
just like an alloy that involves
vibranium but it's not the pure
vibranium that i think the wakandans
would
consider their property and that's why
they were okay with doing it but what do
you think would happen if they took it
like what would that mean
i mean john walker could still juice up
with super soldier serum at that point i
don't know if he needs the shield
the reason why they didn't take it
because it was caused like a really huge
international incident because the field
is such a
huge american symbol
like with the end of black panther with
them trying to establish themselves as a
more open country and like
develop you know relationships with
different countries and all that stuff
they were just like it's not worth it
you know let's just let them have it we
have all the vibranium in the world
anyway
so like you know we don't really need it
um
but yeah it really i think just boils
down to international politics
um and them not really wanting to make a
scene because like they're
they're there to just take zemo they're
supposed to be in and out like no one
like they're sort of like act like
ninjas in a way so like they don't
really want to make a scene
so they're just like i just have it
whatever um well
if if we really wanted it we could take
it any time anyway so
exactly exactly yeah i think i think
that's a good answer mt for sure
uh but let's look ahead to episode five
of next week because it is rumored to be
a big one uh serious creator malcolm
spellman teased that some cameo is
coming
whom he would like to partner with thor
so looking ahead to
what we know is left from promo footage
right we know that like
sam and bucky are probably gonna return
to sam's wilson family home
uh they're gonna somehow get the shield
and throw the shield around
trees um unless that whole story line
was cut and was only in trailers but if
so it'd be weird for them to keep
showing in trailers
we know zemo's going to return to
sokovia because he's going to go to that
sokovian memorial
but uh who do we think this surprise
cameo is going to be
are we going to meet the power broker do
you think i i mean i hope
we meet the power broker eventually at
some point during the series
but i i honestly think and this this
came to my like
brain like a couple of days after we
recorded the rogue theory that we did on
this
um i think it's gonna be d man
demolition man um
that they're going to introduce because
demolition man also got his powers from
the power broker
and as we see with john walker um
juicing himself
up with the power broker jews i think
that we're they're going to sam and
bucky are going to want to learn
more about who's been juiced up by the
power broker potentially
and then that's when we are introduced
to d man who is
a very great character and i really
really sincerely hope that he's in this
series but
what do you think the surprise gave me
that's a big swing for sure
um no i i have a feeling that um
i mean i've been on this mandarin train
for a bit um
just because i think the power broker is
going to be connected to the mandarin in
some ways
maybe not but i think whoever the power
broker is is going to be the one that he
wants to partner with thor
just because there's like a sense of
royalty i think the power brokers
and he's going to have this weird like
alternate uh world
in in madrid that he lives and i think
thor does well with those kind of weird
trippy like
you know rules of uh of respect that one
has to show royalty
uh yeah how thor grew up so maybe that's
what malcolm spellman was talking about
but um someone was also saying this is
someone who's gonna be a very very
grounded character
there's been a lot of theorizing that it
could be the mutant omega red
uh might jump at the show again that
doesn't sound like a very grounded
character maybe
there's nothing more grounded than
mutants eric i see mutants on the
streets every day
yeah yeah yeah so uh yeah i think that
this big cameo i mean
i don't know what other questions they
have we set up someone in wakanda
right or we set up the wakandans the
door milani to show up
what are the people in this world based
with two more episodes left are they
gonna reveal a completely new character
who hasn't even been referenced yet
probably not right so i don't know i
would assume it'd be the power broker
i'm just trying to think from a
screenwriter's perspective
yeah i don't think they would bring in a
character who they did no foreshadowing
of
or no references to or makes would
currently as we know the series make no
sense in the plot
it's going to be a story driven reason
why this character joins
rather than just like hey fans want to
see omega red in this
you know we'll see i mean i hope it's
d-man it would be cool if it was the
power broker
um so we could learn more about them and
you know what
just popped into my mind just now would
it not be crazy this is a crazy idea
what if the valkyrie was the power
broken
that'd be nuts because she's like you
know ruling
like she's on earth and she's part of
asgard and like what if she's just doing
her own thing and just being
a bad person i don't know but like
obviously i don't think that but like
it's something that popped into my mind
yeah she'd be fun and we know what it's
like when she's teamed up with thor
like that is very fun to watch um yeah i
mean
it's uh it's hard to know basically i'm
at the point now with the show where
it's like
loki can't come soon enough
[Laughter]
yeah i'm sort of getting really itchy
for loki because i'm just like yo
there's some really interesting stuff
and i've been reading about the tva and
like oh man
well uh thank you for joining us for
this episode of our falcon winter
soldier after show
empty and are gonna be back next friday
for our reaction episode
five uh we have a lot we gotta get
through i uh
there's gonna be some fun stuff to break
down in this episode for sure uh so i'm
gonna jump on that right now
but uh you can follow mt at
mastertainment follow me at ea boss
follow new rockstar subscribe to these
uh inside marvel podcast feeds wherever
you get your podcast
uh thank you for watching subscribe to
us on youtube and uh we'll close out
with their favorite
moment of the episode looking strong
[Music]
john
[Music]
you